que la lueur de cette braise me conduise
jusqu'à ces hommes dont je suis en quête
guide mes pas jusqu'à ce que je les
trouve et que je les
tue AB
folleur à ma naissance il faisait partie
des qu seuls hommes blancs au Japon l'un
d'entre eux a enlevé ma mère et a fait
de moi un
monstre la soif de meurtre remplit vos
yeux il mérite de
mourir
ce samouraï j'ai vu ses yeux il na rien
d'un
humain je veux connaître tout ce qu'il y
a à savoir au sujet du démon dont tu
parles rien peutarrêter viend il se
tiendra devant
toi il te tranchera la
[Musique]
gorge er aux hommes les femmes en
revanche doivent se montrer pragmatique
j'ai vécu comme une captive ma vie
entière si je meurs aujourd'hui c'est
enfem
libre je me suis promis de me venger je
n'ai pas le temps de m'embarrasser
d'amour ou même d'amitié et surtout pas
de
faébless sous ton masque tu n'es pas le
tueur que tu prétends être tu n'es
qu'une âme en colère
je t'avais prévenu que rien ne pourrait
arrêter ce samouraï mais tu m'as ignoré
ce n'est qu'un homme laiss venir à nous
il n'a rien
d'